[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES MALONE:
Hello, and thank you
for being here today I
sincerely appreciate it.
My name is James
Malone I'm a product
manager with Google Cloud.
And today, I'm
going to be joined
by Zulily in just a little bit.
And I want to talk through the
topic of digging and filling
data lakes.
Specifically, I want
to talk about how
you think about data
lakes, why people create
data lakes, the value
they can provide,
and what they mean in
terms of architecture
on Google Cloud Platform.
So roughly, we're
going to frame what are
data lakes, what do we mean?
Data lakes could
mean a lot of things.
So I want to fill
in specifically
what we're thinking about,
what we're talking about.
I'm going to talk
about if you wanted
to go build a data lake on
GCP, what does that actually
look like?
And then, Zulily is
going to come on stage
and walk through their data
platform, which will give you
an indication of how
somebody has built a data
lake in Google Cloud Platform
in real-life scenario.
So first, what are data lakes?
And why do they matter?
And it's a common phrase.
So if you're familiar with
data lakes, I apologize.
But I do want to
level set, just so we
form a common understanding
of what we mean by data lakes.
So first and
foremost, data lakes
are a collection of raw data.
They could be unstructured data.
They could be structured data.
They could be
semi-structured data.
It's really just a
collection of data
that you've put
in a single store
for a variety of purposes.
So data lake is a good term.
You could look at it as a
giant container of data.
It's essentially a
collection of data
that you're going to
use for some purpose.
And it is in some format.
Data lakes typically
have a few key features.
First, people often
put a lot of raw,
or unprocessed, or preprocessed
data in a data lake.
So it's very common for people
to take all of their data,
and as a first step, just
land it in a data lake
until they know what
they want to do with it.
Second, it is very
common for data lakes
to have a mix of structures.
So you may have a data lake that
has a lot of unstructured data
but is also sprinkled with
semi-structured or structured
data after it's been processed
or in the middle of being
processed.
Data lakes, third, are
not tied to processing.
So data lakes are the
hallmark of the separation
of storage and compute.
So when you store
data in a data lake,
it's not tied to any specific
processing technology.
And most commonly, you'll
see that there's actually
multiple processing
technologies that are used
against one data lake itself.
That leads to data lakes
being multipurpose.
Instead of having one
specialty function,
being really good at
one thing, data lakes
are a jack of all trades
in terms of a data store.
They might not be the best
in one particular function.
But they serve a lot
of functions very well.
Why build data lake?
Well, first,
scalability-- data lakes
are usually very scalable.
So instead of
worrying about things
like how much
capacity do I need,
or how many disks
do I have to buy.
Instead, you just
think of a data lake
as almost an infinite store.
Second, there's less
upfront work required.
A key hallmark of data
lakes is that you can just
put data in without
thinking too much about it.
You're not having to preprocess
the data or pre-apply
schemas to data,
not having to follow
any particular formatting rules.
Data lake, really
in an ideal sense,
should just be as simple as
putting the data in a store.
And you're done.
You can use a variety of
tools with a data lake.
So a good data lake will
have APIs built on top of it.
It will have third
party integrations
that you can use with it.
A data lake should be connected.
A data lake off by
itself or usable only
by a specific set of tools,
that's not a great data lake.
That's just a really
isolated data silo
with maybe more data in
it or a variety of data.
Because it is well connected,
infinitely scalable,
it should really be usable in
a variety of circumstances.
That means organizational
circumstances.
It means in terms
of applications.
You might use the
data for analytics.
You might use the data for ML.
You might use the data just for
archive, and disaster recovery,
and retention.
All of that is done in a
data lake with cost in mind.
So a real big reason
that a lot of people
are interested in data lakes
and build data lakes is cost.
Often, when you reason about
what data to keep or not keep,
you're trying to
think about, well,
how much does the data cost?
Is it worth the
data sitting around?
Maybe I'm going to use it.
Maybe I won't.
Data lake, theoretically,
should remove as many
of those cost
concerns as possible.
So data lakes sound great.
And a lot of people
talk about data lakes.
And there's a lot of
interest in data lakes.
But there's a very
fair question of,
if data lakes are so great, why
isn't everybody building them?
Or why doesn't everybody
already have a data lake?
Well, I would postulate
there's a few reasons for that.
One of the biggest
reasons I would
attribute to Conway's law.
Simply put, your
organizational structure
will often define how you
organize, in some cases,
applications.
But I'm going to
apply it to data.
So essentially, your
organization chart
influences how you think
and break apart data.
So in this very simple
example, you have a set.
Let's say these are
different departments inside
of an organization.
They're going to have their
different applications.
different technologies.
They're going to have
their different needs--
all very legitimate,
all very valid.
That's their view of the world.
Unfortunately, that
siloed view of the world
is driving their
technology choices.
It's driving what data
storage technology they're
thinking about, what
processing tools they're
using, how they think about
structured or unstructured
data.
So without really
thinking about it,
the organizational chart is
actually almost clearly mapping
to the technology choices
that they're going to make.
That makes data
integration really messy.
So now, you have all
of these technologies.
You have some data
that's unstructured.
that's structured.
And it usually creates a
really big plumbing mess
that you then need yet
another group to go and fix.
So you have three different
databases, two data warehouses,
raw data just
sitting everywhere.
And now, you need
a massive effort
to go and try and tie
all of this together.
Now, I think it's fair to
say, most people don't wake up
in the morning and
think, I'm going
to go create just a giant
data mess for myself
because that sounds like fun.
Instead, it's their
organizational chart
that's usually driving a lot
of decisions behind the scenes.
And they just end up in a mess.
Data is also, as a result of
being organizationally driven,
it's not seen as an asset.
It's usually seen as a
cost in a lot of aspects.
So you're thinking about,
OK, what technology
do I need to store this data?
And then, data
becomes a cost center.
And people are buying
technology to store the data.
But at the end of
the day, you're
really just trying to think
about how can I lower my costs?
So how do I optimize costs
versus data being kept?
And instead of actually
deriving value from your data,
you're just sitting there trying
to do accounting on your data.
And I think, it's fair to say
that most people don't find
a lot of value out of doing
accounting on their data,
unless they're dealing
with financial data.
And that's their goal.
It also means that
any duplication
is highly inefficient.
So if you have two groups
that are storing data,
when everything is a cost,
any duplication inside
of two technologies that
groups may not even know
exist outside of that particular
group is extremely inefficient.
It also makes management
a complete headache.
So you have all of these
different organizational
groups.
They have all of the different
applications that are not only
storing but using data.
They have all of these
different retention policies
they may want to apply to data.
They have different
security requirements,
different retention
requirements.
So it usually leads
to programs where
you have to look at
an organizational view
of the world and
profile who has data?
How much data do they have?
Where is that data located?
What are their
retention policies?
What is their security policies?
What are their schemas?
Quite frankly, this usually
leads to large-scale efforts
that take multiple years
to try and create a data
map across an organization.
Again, it might be
a worthwhile effort.
And it's something
that people have
to do to make the world a
better place organizationally.
But it's distracting from
what most people want to do,
which is just actually
use data and drive
value from their data.
A common solution
to this problem
is the drive to data warehouses.
And I'll preface this with
saying data lakes and data
warehouses co-exist.
So don't interpret the slides
saying data lakes and data
warehouses are
diametrically opposed.
They actually co-exist.
And there's really good reasons
why we actually want both.
But a common knee jerk
reaction to the data messiness
that's driven by all of this
organizational complexity
is centralization.
And a very common
form of centralization
is creating the large
scale-data warehouse.
And then, you take
all of these efforts,
and then you design schemas
that are cross-functional.
And you have committees
that try and figure
out what schemas is you need and
how you break everything apart.
You may drive value
from the data warehouse.
But that also introduces its own
complexities in terms of cost,
in terms of getting everybody to
agree on what schemas you want,
in terms of access.
So just driving to a data
warehouse is an end result.
It makes sense in some
cases but not all cases.
So data lakes can simplify and
optimize for these problems.
Very simply, a data
lake can break down
organizational walls.
So it seems very simple
because it is actually
a pretty simple concept.
Instead of focusing on
different data technologies
because you have these
organizational silos,
and you have people thinking
in a box, with a common store,
with a common data lake-- if
you put data in that data lake--
it's much easier to think about.
It's much easier for teams
to see what other teams have.
It's much easier
to store that data.
It's much easier to think
about security, much easier
to think about retention.
All because instead
of trying to silo data
and partition it across
different technologies,
different processing
tools, you're
putting it in one data lake.
I mentioned that data
lakes and data warehouses
are complementary.
And that is very true.
So we'll talk about how data
lakes and data warehouses
are complementary inside of GCP.
But they both have
their purpose.
A data lake is a great, single,
shared, common resource.
It's a great place to
store data of all types.
It's really, in many cases, jack
of all trades, master of none.
Data takes can be read
from many applications.
Data lakes have a great
utility in storing data
until you know what
you want to do with it,
or until you load it
into a subset of data
and often put it
into an application
or a specific purpose.
Now, data warehouses are
really good at what they do.
There are very good
reasons why you
would want to take a subset of
data, and apply schemas to it,
and have subsecond or very low
latency queriability on that
data, ensure that the data
is clean, is formatted,
is consistent.
Data warehouses are
very, very good at that.
not very good at just
storing lots and lots
of data because you
go through the process
of loading that data,
normalizing that data, and
planting schemas for that data.
Likewise, data lakes are
not great at offering
subsecond queries.
Even with tools like Hiver,
and some cases Presto,
you may get to lower
latency queries.
But they're not going to
generally match the semantics
of data warehouses.
So both of these tools
are very complementary
in a data-driven organization.
I want to talk
through how you would
build a data lake on GCP if
you were to get started today.
And this is coming
from the assumption
that you just don't have
any data in GCP at all.
I mentioned a
hallmark of databases
that you have the
single store of data.
And in Google Cloud
Platform, cloud storage
is the hub or the central
spoke of a data lake.
There's a lot of
semantics tied to cloud
storage that make
it the central hub
or spoke for your data lake.
First, you can use it
across many, many products.
cloud storage is well
connected and well integrated
to many cloud platform products.
You can optimize your
cost and availability
based on different availability
tiers, different storage
tiers inside of cloud storage.
I did, in fact, count the number
of nines because I was curious.
And there's nine nines
after the decimal.
There's very high
durability in cloud storage.
You don't need to
think about how
you're going to necessarily back
up your data or what happens.
It's incredibly durable.
You can also apply centralized
management and security
policies.
So if you've not
use cloud storage,
before you can apply
policies on buckets.
You can apply
policies on objects.
You have a lot of flexibility to
specify what happens to items.
And inside of a
data lake, that's
nice because you can do
that in a central place
instead of having to
figure out whichever
number of technologies are
using to try and figure out then
how to apply policies to them.
Something that some people
know about that's not obvious
but one of the most interesting
features for cloud storage
is immediate consistency.
And I'll talk about
this as it pertains
to the Spark and
Hadoop ecosystem,
which I know quite well.
But immediate consistency
is actually really,
really important in a data lake.
The best way to summarize media
consistency is when you put
something in the data lake--
in this case, cloud storage--
it's immediately available
through a list operation
in cloud storage.
This is really important if
you have multiple producers
and consumers that are
pointing at the same bucket.
If somebody puts a
file there, and you
want to immediately
process that file,
you want that file to be
immediately available in a list
operation.
Otherwise, somebody may miss it.
Or worse, if one person
gets it in a list operation
and another person does not get
it in a list operational, all
of a sudden, you
have discontinuity
between two different
users of your data.
So the fact that cloud storage
has immediate list consistency
is actually really,
really important.
In terms of thinking
about a data lake,
the different storage
classes in cloud storage
are very, very important
semantic for building a data
lake on GCP.
There's a couple of really
important points to take here.
First, there is a single
consistent storage API
and availability across
all of these storage tiers.
So instead of having to try,
and reason, and think about,
do I use regional
buckets or Coldline,
and how long does it take to
get something out of Coldline?
Or what different APIs do I
need to use to access Coldline
versus Nearline?
You don't have to think
about different APIs.
You don't have to think about
latency for getting things out
of Coldline.
You don't need to introduce
seconds, minutes, hours
for getting data between
these availability tiers.
The availability tiers also
allow you to pick and choose.
Sometimes, there are
very valid reasons
why you want things
available very, very quickly.
There are a lot of times you may
want something that costs less,
but you're going to
access less frequently.
So in lot of cases, people
will take archived data
that they don't expect to use,
and they'll put it in Coldline.
You can also apply policies
on buckets and on objects.
And that's actually
really important.
So in this case, say you
have a bunch of things.
And you keep them in
a regional bucket.
And then after 30 days, you
want to put them in Nearline.
You keep them in
Nearline for 30 days,
and then, you put them
in Coldline for a year.
This is really important
because this is actually
very similar to how a
lot of organizations
think about and use data.
There's generally only a
subset of data, which they
are using with any regularity.
It's very uncommon for people
to use all of their data
all the time.
It's very common for people to
access or work on their most
recent data most frequently.
And they still want access
to their older data.
But they don't necessarily need
access all the time or access
is very, very infrequent.
And there's a lot
of reasons for that.
The data that people
produce changes over time.
The trustworthiness or
accuracy of the data
may change over time.
It doesn't mean you want
to get rid of the data.
It just means that
you don't necessarily
need access to it all the time.
Data lakes fit into a flow
in thinking about data.
So when you ingest data,
it's very, very common
to ingest data into
that data lake.
And then, trying to figure
out-- or maybe already
know-- but that
data lake is there
until you take action on that
data in some way or some form.
So for example, you may ship all
of your logs, all of your blob
data.
You may have images.
Store all of that
in your data lake.
In some cases, people
already know what
they want to do with that data.
And they just take a
subset of that data,
and process it, and put it in
maybe a transactional database
or some front of house system.
In other cases, people may want
to keep data in that data lake,
until they know what to do.
And that's the power
of a data lake.
It gives you that flexibility
to keep the data at rest.
You may immediately
act on a subset of it
and put it in a
particular place.
And you only have to
act on a subset of it.
You don't have to keep the
whole data chunk in one piece,
putting it in a more
specialized system.
Or you can just
keep the data there
until you know what
you want to do with it.
There's multiple
places where you
may want to think about
loading and reading data inside
of Google Cloud Platform.
There's a lot of
text on this slide.
Thankfully, a lot of people are
taking pictures of the slide.
All of this is also
documented online
in a guide that I will post a
link to at the very end here.
But the key point
I want to make here
is GCS, as the center
of your data lake,
is great for just storing
large amounts of data.
There are other storage
products that you can
use for more specific needs.
So application-based needs,
you may want data inside
of an enterprise data warehouse.
And you load it into BigQuery.
You may want to put data
inside of Cloud Spanner.
But most likely,
you're not going
to want to put all of your
data in Cloud Spanner.
All of your data is not
appropriate for Big Table.
So with cloud storage, you
can keep all of your data
in a centralized data
lake and then use
each technology appropriately
for a very specific purpose.
There's multiple ways that
you can fill cloud storage.
So hypothetically,
say you have a lot
of data that's just existing
somewhere in the known
universe.
There's batch ways you
can load that data.
So you can use gsutil which
ships as part of the Google
Cloud SDK.
There's a Storage
Transfer Service.
You can use
something like distcp
if you're using the Spark
and Hadoop ecosystem.
Actually that's
very, very common
for people that are moving data
from HDFS to cloud storage.
You can stream the data
using something like Pub/Sub
and Cloud Dataflow.
There's also a
transfer appliance.
number of partners
who can help you move data
to cloud storage in both
a one-time and
replicated way depending
on whichever needs you have.
I want to provide some
conceptual examples
before I invite Zulily
to stage to provide
a very practical example of
how data lake on GCP is useful
and how that works in
theory and in practice.
A really good example
is replacing HDFS
in a Spark and Hadoop cluster--
very common for people to
have Spark and Hadoop clusters
to store data and for them
to scale that cluster out
because they need to
store more data in HDFS.
As an example of how
cloud storage can
be a really good
data lake in GCP,
there's a Hadoop compatible
file system connector,
or there's a connector
that implements the Hadoop
compatible file system API
available for Cloud Dataproc--
which means that you
can just read and write
to and from cloud storage
via Spark and Hadoop.
And you don't have to
think about HDFS anymore.
That also frees you from having
to think about replication.
It frees you from having
to think about scalability.
It also generally is
incredibly performant.
So you'll actually often
see much better performance
from cloud storage
with Cloud Dataproc
than reading and writing even to
something like persistent disk.
It doesn't necessarily
mean that you
would want to use cloud storage
for everything in the sun.
In some cases,
temporary IO may be
more appropriate on local SSD.
It may mean that you want to
parallelize your workloads
and avoid doing things
like massive renames.
But in general, the nice thing
about having cloud storage
as a data lake is you're
no longer thinking
about the biggest pain, which
is that underlying file system
and how you actually manage that
file system to store your data.
I mentioned consistency.
This is a good example of
why consistency is important.
If you have multiple
Spark and Hadoop
clusters that are
reading and writing
from one bucket
at the same time,
they all need to be in
sync in terms of what
they see in that bucket.
If they're out of sync, you're
going to get different results.
So you're just dropping a
new file in every second.
And all you're
doing in a Spark job
is counting the number of files.
Something that
simple, if you don't
have immediate
consistency, you're
going to get different
results very, very quickly.
So consistency is a
really, really big deal
for a data lake.
And it's also a
really good example
of why cloud storage is a
very, very good data lake.
I mentioned segmenting
data by classes.
So people generally don't
access all of the data at once.
It's usually a very, very
small portion of their data,
which means that in
a traditional world--
in this case, HDFS--
they're paying one cost
for all of their data
even though they're only
accessing a small portion
of their data frequently.
With different
storage classes, you
can keep that
frequently-accessed data
in something like a
regional bucket and then
start segmenting your
data to different classes
depending on how
frequently you think
or you just know you
need to access that data.
You also have a choice
of processing tools
with cloud storage.
So in this case, if you
have data in cloud storage,
you can read that data
from Cloud Dataproc.
You can read it from Dataflow.
You can do Federated queries
on that data from BigQuery.
You can analyze that
data with Cloud Dataprep.
In this example, say you analyze
the data in Cloud Dataprep,
and then, you load a subset
of that data into BigQuery--
a very good example of
a data lake in action.
Very likely, all of the
data that you would analyze
with something like
Dataprep, you're
not going to just dump
into BigQuery because say,
you remove 15% of data.
That's just not what you
need to keep in BigQuery.
In all likelihood,
you don't want
to immediately just destroy
that data, which gives you
a very nice separation
between the appropriateness
of BigQueries in
Enterprise Data Warehouse
and cloud storage
as a data lake.
You also have the flexibility
of file formats in cloud storage
and in general with data lakes.
So in this case, say
you have data that's
Parquet, and Avro, and ORC.
You don't have to think
about different storage
mediums for each type
of these file formats.
Within even the
same folder, you can
have files of all these
file formats coexist.
As long as the consumer
knows what to expect
or can introspect the files and
deal with them appropriately,
you're good to go.
You don't have to
configure your data lake
and manage based
on the file format.
There's a lot of
boxes on this line.
The important takeaway
is cloud storage
can be the central spoke
of your data platform
as a data lake on GCP.
So for example, you
could read data and batch
from Dataflow or Dataproc.
You can stream data from
Pub/Sub, from Dataflow.
You can refine that
data, put it in something
like Spanner, BigQuery.
But at the Hub, all
of your just data--
either that's been
processed or raw data--
is inside of cloud storage.
It has your data lake.
With that, I want to invite
our friends from Zulily
to stage to walk through
a practical example of how
they built a data lake on GCP.
GAURAV TANDON: I'm happy to be
here and share our experiences
on board the GCP, the Google
Cloud Platform, 40 years ago,
and specifically talk about
what Google Cloud Storage meant
for us and did for us among
the other data products
that Google has to offer.
So this presentation
is really talking
about analytics, and
machine learning,
and how cloud
storage can actually
be a repository for
doing all of that.
A little bit about myself.
I'm director of machine
learning data science at Zulily.
It's a loosely defined role.
Machine learning data science
can mean very different things
at different organizations.
But at Zulily,
what this means is,
I work with multiple teams
of data scientists, machine
learning engineers,
and data engineers
to drive experiences that engage
our customers-- whether they
are external customers
or internal customers
within the retail enterprise.
So what is Zulily?
Zulily is growing and
thriving in its own category
of e-commerce.
And that's making shopping,
entertaining, and fun.
We present a third
way to shop, which
is discovery-based shopping,
unlike brick and mortar
retailers and traditional
online retailers, which
are intent-based,
directed source-driven.
Zulily is more about a browse
and discover experience.
So it's a commeditized search.
If you want cat food, you
go search for cat food.
You'll find a bunch of options.
You pick the one you like,
most relevant to your needs,
and you go buy something.
Zulily is not that.
You think about Zulily as
a newspaper or magazine.
There is a new
edition every day.
And the goal is, we want
to drive engagement.
We want our customers
to be curious about what
do we have on the site
today and come back
to see what's new and fresh.
So how do we do that?
We launch over 9,000
products every single day
through 100 plus sales
events on our website.
We work with around 15,000
brands to make this happen.
So it's an interesting
business model.
But what it requires is the
agility and the nimbleness
across the board because
we are really revamping,
relaunching that same
site over and over again
every single day.
And what it also
means is, we have
to make data accessible
to all of our partners
within the organization,
whether they are merchandisers
we're working with, the external
vendors to get their products
onto the Zulily platform.
Or they are
marketing specialists
who are trying to figure out
what kind of ad campaigns
to launch the same day, the
next day, or the next week.
Data is key.
We also have three fulfillment
centers in the United States.
And so we want all
of our associates
in the fulfillment
center to have access
to data near real-time
and really drive
their decision making
using that data.
So that was really the goal and
how we are as an organization.
So where is Zulily today?
By the way, we launched in 2010.
So we are a relatively
young company, 8-year-old.
But right now, 70% of
our orders are actually
placed through mobile devices.
And 91% of our
orders are actually
coming through repeat customers.
And that is the key.
And that is really the
focus of this talk.
It didn't happen overnight.
It's a process that
we went through.
So what was our journey
where we ended up here?
And how did Google help in that
journey to make this happen?
We lost the presentation
on that site.
OK.
So four years ago, the
business was growing.
Our product categories
were expanding.
The customer base was
growing significantly.
And that is a time
where the company,
we recognized that the
structure we had in place
did not meet the needs for
our future growth potential.
That's where we started looking
at what are our options.
We started looking
at the big data.
But at the core
of that, we really
wanted to make our
own big data platform.
We are a tech company at heart.
We have a bias to build, a
very strong bias to build.
And from that perspective, we
went back to the drawing board
and said, hey, we want to
build this big data platform
to democratize data
to all of our partners
internally and also
improve our customer
experience to those who are
coming to our site every day.
So there were key
components there.
Back in the day, we had silos of
data, unstructured data coming
through clickstream.
Who's clicking on what page?
What products are they viewing?
Which one they added to cart?
What did they purchase?
So all of that
data is coming in.
It's all unstructured.
On the other hand, we had
transactional data stores.
Every application, whether
it's the products customers
are buying to our
marketing campaigns.
All of that data lived in
traditional SQL-like data
stores.
So we wanted to get
everything together.
Correlating something
from a user interaction
and unstructured data
in the clickstream,
to something on our
transactional DB
was a hard thing at that time.
So it was clear to us.
We had to get the data
together in a single place
and then figure out
a mechanism to make
it available to everyone
and in a timely fashion.
Scalability was important.
Reliability, durability,
flexibility-- our business
is really flexible.
So we wanted to have factor
in all the flexibility upfront
before we proceeded
with anything.
We had workloads with
varying requirements.
Some of them would
be batch processes
that we would run once a day.
Some were every 30 minutes.
But there were also a desire to
get the data in near real time.
So there was definitely a
real time component of that.
And we wanted part
of all of that data,
which in the first place, we
didn't know what data we needed
and how we would use that data.
And that's where the
data lake came in,
the centralized data storage.
Can we just put all of the
data, pocket somewhere,
and over time, we'll
figure out what's
the best use of that data.
And as we determine
what that user
scenario, the key scenario, is
that we're trying to target,
that's when we will do all
of the transformations.
And magic will
happen on this data.
And we will make it available
in our big data warehouse, which
will be available to the
rest of the organization.
And they will run their business
from this big data warehouse.
Data access and
visualization is key.
We do a lot of reporting.
Like I mentioned, our
fulfillment centers
need to know what's the
status of all the orders,
how is shipping happening.
Our marketers need to know
how their ad campaigns are
performing over the
course of the day.
Do we need to course
correct something based
on the data we are seeing?
So there was a strong desire
to get data as soon as possible
and also be able to visualize
it for easier consumption.
And the core data services,
which we're really
making that data
available to everyone,
whether it's a non-tech
partner in different parts
of the organization, or
it is for consumption
within the technology
organization itself.
So our journey was more around
the centralized big data
storage.
We evaluated Google
Cloud Storage.
We really liked that it
supported all of our needs
from the structure to
the unstructured data.
And like I said, at the
time, we were not even clear.
We had a few course scenarios
we wanted to address.
But we wanted to
future-proof ourselves.
So it really fed the deeds.
For the big data
warehouse, it was BigQuery.
And again there, we have
over 100-plus disparate data
sources that we are
actually pulling
the data from at
different time intervals.
Some of them are near real time.
Some of them running every
hour or every day cadence.
So we've had to build
some tooling around that.
We built some
capability internally
that would actually
synchronize the data
from the disparate sources,
whether it's a SQL data
store, non-sequel data
store, or just gathering
all of the real-time
clickstream and make
it available in the centralized
data storage, that's
GCS, Google Cloud Storage.
And then, we actually used
a lot of static clusters
in the beginning and then
moved on to Google Dataproc
to actually solve for some
of the core scenarios that
were critical for the
rest of the organization.
So what are the key data
sets that we wanted to make
available to the
rest of the company
that they can actually drive
their day-to-day business from?
So we used Spark and Hadoop to
do all of the batch processing.
In some cases, we
used Spark Streaming
for real-time processing.
And we made that data
available in BigQuery.
And BigQuery was great because
the barrier to entry is low.
It's not just limited to
data scientists and analysts.
It's a very easy
SQL-like interface
that I think half of our company
actually, or more than half
the company actually, uses it.
It's interesting because our
PR team just told me, hey,
I went into BigQuery
the other day.
And I got this data.
So that was pretty
cool to see how
people outside of technology
are embracing it and being
able to leverage, to run
their decision making,
to run the business.
So that's really what
I was talking about,
which is we wanted
to make the data
available as a
self-service capability
to the rest of the business.
BigQuery is what we used.
But really, it was the data
from Google Cloud Storage
and manipulating,
transforming that data,
joining multiple
data sets together
to actually make something
meaningful and compelling
for our business
stakeholders to consume.
That is what is
available in BigQuery.
And they can do all of
the reporting that's
boarding on top of that.
They can actually get
any intraday statistics
that they need to answer some
of the business questions.
The other thing which
was really interesting
and was an outcome of this, we
have a lot of in-built tools
and applications.
I mentioned, we have a huge
merchandising organization
that's getting all of our
vendors on board the platform.
What we want to do is,
over the course of the day,
as the products are
launched on the site,
can we provide some insights
to our merchandisers
and our external vendors on--
1, how their
products are actually
performing on the site?
How much demand are
they generating?
What does conversion look like?
And really give them the
data and the insights
they need to take action.
And so we built some
applications around that.
This is an example of our
merchandising dashboard.
It's an application
which is used by over 500
people within the company.
But really, this is driving
them to look at the data,
and consume the data
in an easy fashion,
and then have something
that's actionable as a result
of looking at this data and
the visualization itself.
So once we rolled
this application out,
we really saw there was high
engagement in our organization.
And they really started to pick
up on big data and the Google
Cloud Platform itself.
The other thing I
wanted to stress on
is, we have a dynamic
business model.
Our catalog is
changing every day.
We want to get people to come
back to our site every day.
So we do that with
personalization.
It's a one-to-one
hyper-personalized experience
for every customer.
So in that sense,
we are actually
serving millions of versions
of our site every day.
And we do it with
the power of the data
that we are gathering from all
of the disparate data sources,
trying to understand, what
do our customers like?
What are their preferences?
And really, hear from
them and learn from them.
And then, take those
learnings to drive
their future experiences.
In this case, I
have the same day,
same time that three
different customers who
came to the Zulily site.
On your left, extreme
left, is a customer who
buys apparel and fitness gear.
In the middle was
a shopper who came
through footwear advertisement
and landed on our site.
And on the extreme
right is a customer
who predominantly buys for
her kids and home goods.
So you can see the experience
is radically different for all
of our customers.
And this is key to
driving engagement.
This goes back to by
doing all of that,
we were able to get to--
91% of our orders
today are actually
coming from repeat customers.
We have over 6.1 million
active customers today.
Our number of active customers
has grown 24% year over year.
Our revenues at the end of Q1
had grown 17% year over year.
Currently, we are
at $1.6 billion.
And one of the things
I wanted to mention--
I mentioned this in the context
of the data platform itself--
is the data lives in
Google Cloud Storage.
We are gathering
all of the data.
But even to power the machine
learning and personalization
experience, we are actually
leveraging the Hadoop Spark
ecosystem, the Dataproc clusters
that Google has to offer.
And using that, we
are creating all the
features that we need to drive
the personalization experience.
And again, depending on
what kind of features
we are building, what
kind of transformations
the cadence will vary.
Some are near real-time.
Some are every half hour,
every day, and so forth.
One of the other
interesting challenges
here is, people who weren't
familiar with the machine
learning personalisation
recommendation systems
space is, there is an inherent
presentation bias in machine
learning jargon.
And what does that mean?
That means, if a customer
never sees a product,
they're never going
to click on it.
If they're never clicking to it,
they're never going to buy it.
So one of the places where
we use Google Cloud Storage
was also to address that
problem of presentation bias.
How do we bring transparency
into what we do and how we do,
and share it with
our business partners
so they understand what is the
exposure that personalization
is driving through
the customer base.
And we did that by
having all of our logs.
So when we are serving--
by the way, these are
served in near real-time.
So as we are serving
these experiences
to customers based on their
latest and greatest data,
we are actually logging
those experiences.
And we make those
logs available in GCS,
which helps us to actually mine
those logs after the fact--
or during the course of the
day at periodic intervals--
and be able to present
reports and dashboards to all
of our partners, telling them
how personalization is actually
driving exposure from our
customers on the products
that they cared about which
was very insightful as well.
So I mentioned
briefly how it works.
We are launching millions
of sites every day.
We receive all of that data.
We process that data.
This is where Google Cloud
Storage comes into the picture.
We are using Dataproc cluster
to train on machine learning
models based on the
features that we
are deriving from that data.
And we are using that to
inform the future experiences
for our customers .
It drives higher
revenue engagement.
But above all, it makes
our customers happy.
So there are other places where
my partners the marketing side
are actually using that data
to actually figure out what
the customer lifetime value is.
And they do that by really
looking at that data
again and seeing, OK, who
are our existing high-value
customers?
What were the
behaviors that actually
separate these from the rest?
And as we are trying to
acquire new customers,
can we actually find who
those high-value customers
are based on the behaviors
that they are exhibiting?
So again, it unlocks,
unleashes a lot of power,
a lot of capability that
you can build on top.
So it's been a great journey.
I talked about all
of the positives.
I do want to talk about what
are some of the key challenges
as well.
One of the things that James
mentioned I want to echo--
which was a positive,
and I missed it--
was the strong consistency.
We are actually gathering
this data at scale.
It's really high volume.
We're looking at billions
of key data points
over the course of the day.
So we want to make sure as one
process is writing the data,
while the other process
is reading that data,
it has the latest
and greatest data.
So the imaged consistency
in Google Cloud Storage
is critical to enable that.
So what are the challenges?
And what are things that
would be great to have?
I mentioned at the
beginning of my talk
that this is more on repository
for analytics and machine
learning.
If it's a repository, it has to
have some mechanism of making
that data discoverable.
Currently, that is one of
the challenges we deal with.
We're the different teams
generating different data sets.
How do we make sure that
we are able to re-use
some of the capability a
different team has already
produced?
How do we enable that
ease of discovery
in the Google Cloud Storage?
One of the things I've loved
working with the Google team
is the collaboration,
that we work together
to identify such problems
and make improvements
on the products.
So that is a conversation
we are having.
I don't want to steal
any thunder from them.
But this is something that's
critical to me personally.
And I recognize that it is for
other partners, other companies
as well.
The other is regulations.
So we are living
in a world where
regulations are revolving.
They're compliance.
So how do we ensure
that all of these data
sets that we've
accrued over time is--
how easy is it to incorporate a
new regulation, new compliance,
or legal clause?
That's one of the challenges
where we had to rethink--
again, we are a
relatively young company,
just been there eight years.
We never had to deal
with decades-old data.
But that's something that we've
started thinking about now,
is what is that data
retention policy?
And how does that play
into Google Cloud Storage?
So for people who are actually
on-boarding Google Now,
I think that would be one of
the things you should just
bake in and think
about now versus later.
Data annotation, duplication
ties into data discovery.
But this is, again,
more on duplication.
I'll be repeating the
work, and we actually
take advantage of the work
that somebody else has
done to generate a data
set and use that instead.
So those are the
things that I think
are really top of mind for me.
And I would love to solve.
And I would love to solve it
in collaboration with Google.
So I will pass on
the mic to James.
And we will be open
to questions in a bit.
JAMES MALONE: Thank
you very much.
All right, so before we
leave and take questions--
we may have a few minutes
for questions here--
I wanted to leave you
with a few resources
that you could look at,
that you could get involved
with for more information.
If this was interesting, if this
topic is near and dear to you,
we wanted to point you
in the right direction.
So there is a talk.
It is happening.
And it's actually
after this talk.
It's an IO talk on
moving data to the cloud.
It's going to cover much more
specifically how you actually
do something like move large
sets of data to cloud storage.
If that topic is interesting
to you, please do check it out.
There's also a lot
of documentation
on the cloud.google.com site
for building a data lake,
thinking about the lifecycle of
data on Google Cloud Platform,
and using data in
cloud storage as a data
lake with our big data tools.
You also find that a lot of
the products like Dataproc,
or Dataflow, BigQuery actually
have their own documentation as
well for working
with cloud storage
for usually more
specific use cases,
whether it'd be something
like Spark Streaming,
or streaming an Apache
Beam, or doing a Federated
query in BigQuery.
So if you are curious on how
to use cloud storage as a data
lake with product x,y, or z,
I would actually recommend--
look at the documentation for
that product, and usually,
you will find that--
[MUSIC PLAYING]